من الخرطوم ينضم الى دكتور منتصر محمد
عثمان مدير الاداره العامه للطوارئ الصحيه
ومكافحه الاوبئه في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
اهلا بكم معنا الى اي حد ما هي الجهود
المبذوله الان من اجل
مساعده المستشفيات بعد هذا الوضع المدري
التي الذي وصلت اليه دكتور منتصر
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله
تعالى انه
وقت تقل
الاشكالات الصحيه والاشكالات الاجتماعيه
بالنسبه لنا في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
40 مع كل الولايات بالذات الولايات الا
كثر عندنا حوالي
تسعه ولايات متاثرين بصوره
كبيره في العمل للعمل التالي
من ضمنهم بدايه الخرطوم هي الاكثر تعصرا
وتعاقبها
ولاياتور وشمال دارفور عندنا برضو لا
يتغرب ولايه شمال كردفان
ولايات الشماليه
وولايه الوسط دارفور
كلهم متاثرين للاسف الشديد
بالحادث الان
الاخوه السوداني
وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه المتابعه كان في
استعداد استعلامنا كان على اساس انه نحن
نتوقع انه يكون عندنا مشكله كبيره في
انتشار الامراض
بالنسبه لنا كان عندنا الاشكالات اللي هي
[موسيقى]
عندهم
مخزون استراتيجي
الولايات للاسف الشديد المخزون الافتراضي
لا يكفي للتصدي
الان مجابهين
بها لنقل الجثث من الشوارع لانه كان هناك
فيديوهات تبعناها اليوم الجثث ما زالت
ملقاه في الشوارع
طيب اختي الكريمه انا ممكن اقول لك الان
نحن عندنا اكثر من 3000 مسجل ثلاثه الف
جنيه و60 حاله اصابه وعندنا 346 حالات
مسجله حتى الان بالنسبه لنا في الفيتامين
الموجوده في الشوارع للاسف الشديد هي ما
مسجله في جزء كبير ما عدا ولايه شمال
دارفور اللي هم بالعمل
عن طريق وزاره الصحه مع الاجارات الاخرى
المعنيه اللي هم قاموا بادوارهم في دور
بتاع تامين مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
هل هي وزاره الداخليه وزاره الدفاع في
انها تعمل لنا الكوادر الصحيه ان تقوم
بالع
مل في جسامين يعني حتى الان الممرات للاسف
الشديد في المناطق الصراع لا توجد نظرات
امنه
طب هل هل تقومون بالاتصال بالاطراف
المتنازعه من اجل تامين هذه الممرات حتى
تتمكنوا من ايصال المساعدات الطبيه الى
المستشفيات وايضا نقل هذه الجثث الى
المستشفيات
في عمل فني نحن نقوم بالاجراء الاجراء
الفني بالاتصال بكل الكوارث اللي هي عامله
معنا اذا كان على مستوى
اللجنه الطوارئ الصحيه الانسانيه وهو
الانسانيه واذا كان على مستوى الطوارئ
نقوم بادوارنا في انه للاتصال لكن للاسف
الشديد في المناط
ق اللي هي الصراع هي مناطق
محدده اذا كان في ولايه الخرطوم وباقي
الولايات
الكادر الطبي والكادر الصحي للاسف الشديد
اثرت علينا تماما في العمل في المستشفيات
والمناطق الصحيه في المناطق اللي فيها
ضرب نار شكرا لك من الخرطوم دكتور منتصر
محمد عثمان مدير الاداره العامه للطوارئ
الصحيه ومكافحه الاوبئه في وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه
من الخرطوم ما اعود مجددا الى ضيفنا مصباح
احمد رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه
القوميه والقياده في الحريه والتغيير
استسماح اهلا بك معنا اتمنى ان يكون الصوت
الان اوضح كنا نتحدث عن جهود تقومون بها
من اجل تمديد هذه الهدنه ومن ثم البناء
على وقف اطلاق نار يعني تام هل يمكن ان
تطلعنا على هذه الجهود هل يتم الاتصال
بالسيد حميتي والسيد برهان شخصيا ام
تتفاوضون مع اشخاص ولجان مقربه من
الشخصيتين
نعم هنالك جهود مبزوله من القوى السياسيه
ومن
كذلك الاليه الثلاثيه والرباعيه الدوليه
وعدد من
الدوليين من الدول على راس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هدفها الاساسي تمديد
هذه الهدنه او الحاجه تثبيت هذه الهدنه
وكذلك هنالك اقتراحات بضروره ان تكون
هنالك اليه وطنيه لمراقبه الهدنه وتحديد
المسارات
الامنه للمواطنين
الطبيه للحركه كل ذلك هنالك اقتراحات يجري
ببحثها الان انه ضروره ان تكون هنالك اليه
وطنيه متفق عليها للمشاركه الطرفين طب هل
هل لمستم استاذ مصباح اي
نيه عند الطرفين لهذه المصالحه لانه البعض
يعتبر انه قبل هذه الاشتباكات لن يكون كما
بعده يعني
هاتين الشخصيتين لن يكونوا كما كانوا قبل
هذه الاش تباكات لن يعودوا كرئيس ونائب
رئيس للمجلس السيادي
طبعا الجهود الان مصبغه حول معالجه الوضع
الانساني ونتخذ من الهدنه دي مدخل
وقف اطلاق النار اذا تم ايقاف اطلاق النار
وتم الجلوس التفاوض مؤكد ان الطرفين
سيتواصلان الى تفاهمات لانه مهما كانت
التعقيدات الامور فان الخلاف بينهما يجب
ان يحل ما ليس هنالك مجال استمرار هذه
الحرب
طبعا الخلاف لم يكن جديدا قبل ذلك هم
جلسوا وتوافقوا على بعض النقاط ولكن
تزادت زادت الامور تعقيدا في المرحله
الاخيره سنعوي اولا على ضروره وقفه الطاقه
النار
وتمديد هذه الهدنه لتكون ما هي بدايه لوقف
اطلاق النار بصوره كامله والعوده الى مسار
التفاوض بصوره يشارك فيها كل
المعنيين بهذه العمليه السياسيه وكذلك
ايضا الشركاء
سؤال مهم جدا يعني بعد حل سيد البرهان
للدعم السريع يعني بالنسبه للجيش السوداني
الدعم السريع لم يعد موجودا لانه قام بحله
فعلى هل هناك من تصور لكيفيه المصالحه
بينهما وهناك جهاز كامل تم حله
وقطعا القرار نفسه هنالك اشكالات قانونيه
نعلم ان الدعم السريع ثم انشاءه بقانون
توجيه في البرلمان وليس بقرار جمهوري يعني
ولديه قانون مجاز وبالتالي هنالك تعقيدات
قانونيه في هذا الكلام ربما يكون هذا
القرار الذي صدر من السيد القائد العام هو
نتيجه
للانفعالات التي صاحبت اندلاع هذه الحرب
ومؤكد في ظروف الحروب بتكون هنالك قرارات
وبتكون هنالك ايضا كل طرف يحاول ان ينزع
الشرعيه من الطرف الاخر ولكن اذا تم
الجلوس للحوار والتفاوض مؤكد سيتم تجاوز
هذه النقاط العالقه وليس مهما ان يتم
التراجع عن هذا القرار اذا كان في مصلحه
الوطن احنا الان وقف الحرب ومصلحه الوطن
ومعالجه هذه الازمه بصوره جذريه وبالتالي
لا اعتقد ان هذا القرار سيكون عائق على
الاطلاق نحن ايضا لمسنا من اطراف تاكيدات
بالحوار يعني اذا كان هم يعني غير معنيين
بالدعم السريع ما كان ابدي اشارات بانهم
مستعدون للحوار والتفاوض وبالتالي في
تقدير ان هذه النقاط يمكن معالجتها اذا
التزم الطرفان بوقف
والجلوس في تفاوض اشكرك من الخرطوم مصباح
احمد رئيس دائره الاعلام في حزب الامه
القومي والقياده في الحريه والتغيير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات